[Music]  nobody's born smart we all start at zero  [Music]  can't talk can't walk certainly can't do  algebra adding reading riding riding a  bike nobody's good at anything at first  there was a time when Einstein couldn't  count to ten and Shakespeare had to  learn his ABCs just like the rest of us  thankfully were born to learn slowly  surely he stumbles slip crawl fall and  fail and fall frustrating confusing  trying struggling until one day you walk  one foot in front of the other one idea  on top of the next each wrong answer  making your brain a little bit stronger  failing is just another word for growing  and you keep going this is learning  knowing that you'll get it even if you  haven't gotten it yet because the most  beautiful complex concepts in the whole  universe are built on basic ideas  anywhere can understand whoever you are  wherever you are you only have to know  one thing you can learn anything